je vous demande d'applaudir sandrine
taux légal aux jo draine bonjour à tous
et à toutes
je vous propose maintenant de faire un
exercice pendant 20 secondes
je vous invite à ne penser à rien vous
êtes prêts c'est parti
les 20 secondes se sont écoulées
cet exercice est terminée peut-être que
cet exercice a été facile pour vous pour
la majorité des gens avec qui je
travaille de penser à rien et très
difficile un et client m'a dit sandrine
ce fut les 20 secondes les plus longues
de ma vie je recommencerai plus jamais
notre esprit est fait pour penser comme
nos poumons sont faits pour respirer
nous pouvons noter c'est bientôt fini
cet exercice une pensée du futur c'est
très intéressant le tome précédent
une pensée du passé c'est fascinant de
comprendre comment notre cerveau notre
esprit fonctionne cet exercice nous
rappelle une de mes clientes stéphanie
directrice financière
stéphanie est venu me voir parce qu'
elle ne se sentait pas à la hauteur de
son travail de sa famille elle perdez
confiance en elle
lorsqu'elle était à son travail elle
partait dans mille projets
lorsqu'elle était à la maison avec ses
enfants en train de faire les devoirs
elle pensait à son travail n'était pas
vraiment avec eux elle était désemparée
face à cet esprit qui saute de branche
en branche comme un petit singe
incapable de se poser un instant
naturellement notre esprit part dans le
passé dans le futur nous nous jugeons
nous nous comparons et nous sommes
rarement dans l'instant présent
or l'instant présent c'est le seul et
l'unique moment que nous avons pour
vivre pleinement cette connexion à
l'instant présent nous permet de prendre
conscience de la réalité de nos vies de
nos besoins et de notre leadership
voilà plusieurs dîners année je vivais
une crise tant personnel que
professionnel je me suis épuisé à en
faire toujours plus toujours mieux
déconnecté de qui j'étais vraiment mon
corps exprimé son besoin sont mécontents
ce moment et je n'écoutais pas j'ai pris
du poids j'avais d'eczéma
alors j'avais le choix soit de ne rien
remettre en question et de voir cette
crise peut être s'empirer soin de me
relier à la réalité et de vivre une vie
épanouie j'ai fait le second choix en
apprenant la méditation de pleine
conscience
aujourd'hui j'ai appris à vivre dans
l'instant présent à me relier à mon
corps à mes émotions à mes aspirations
profondes
jour après jour je m'épanouis et je
deviens le leader de ma vie aujourd'hui
j'accompagne des femmes et des hommes à
développer grâce à la méditation de
pleine conscience leur leadership
alors qu'est ce que c'est leadership
pendant longtemps j'ai cru que le
leadership
c'était de diriger ou de motiver les
gens à faire ce que le leader voulez
qu'il fasse
il s'agissait de faire preuve d'autorité
plus ou moins déguisés être un leader
encore aujourd'hui est associé aux
valeurs dites masculines de toujours
plus ses qualités ne sont pas uniquement
attribuable aux hommes de nombreuses
femmes ont elles aussi développer ses
compétences
nous avons tous en nous une part dites
masculines et il part dite féminine
ce sont des qualités humaines
universelles et puis à un moment donné
notre histoire ses qualités masculine de
performance d'autorité de rapport de
force était nécessaire au monde dans
lequel nous vivions nous devions faire
face à une tribu violentes ou un animal
qui risquait de nous dévorer être dans
cette logique de toujours plus et est
nécessaire à notre survie
parce qu'on vivait dans un monde de
pénurie or aujourd'hui notre cerveau
reproduit automatiquement ses schémas
archaïques
il n'observe on ne fait pas la
différence entre la taxe d'un lion et la
remontrance d'un nos managers
il voit cela comme une menace
réagissant comme une attaque en nous
mettant en rapport de force ou créant
des stress nous nous maintenons dans
cette logique de toujours plus nous
consommons toujours plus d'énergie
fossile nous avons intensifié notre
agriculture notre industrie nous avons
divisé le travail est rare chizé pour
plus de performance force est de
constater que le leadership à la jack
welch ne fonctionne plus une étude de
maximiser montre que 77 % des leaders
pensent est bon a motivés et engagés
leurs collaborateurs alors que 82 % des
collaborateurs ne sont pas d'accord nous
vivons une crise collective 300 millions
de personnes dans le monde sont en
dépression
ce qui en fait la principale cause
d'incapacité au travail
de plus la situation de l'homme est en
péril de consommons 1,7 fois la capacité
de régénération de la planète
la réponse à cette crise
elle est plus à l'intérieur de nous qu'à
l'extérieur les leaders de demain sera
réconcilier les valeurs masculines aux
valeurs féminines car en excès cette
énergie masculine crée du stress un
déséquilibre alors quelles sont les
qualités féminines dont nous parlons les
qualités d'intériorité de prendre soin
de soi et des autres
la méditation permet de développer les
compétences dont le leader de demain a
besoin
les études irm ont montré que la
méditation permettait de d'épaissir la
matière grise de nombreuses régions du
cerveau
l'épaississement du cortex préfrontal
indique notamment la meilleure
résolution de problèmes régulation des
émotions est également l'amélioration
des pensées positives
qu'est ce que c'est la méditation de
pleine conscience ou la mindfulness et
bien c'est un entraînement de l'esprit à
être dans l'ici et maintenant alors pour
pratiquer ses compétences
je vous invite maintenant à faire un
exercice cet exercice je l'appelais
pause
je vous invite à vous asseoir
confortablement sur votre siège
et puis peut-être ressentir le contact
des pieds avec le sol
la première étape c'est le p de prendre
un ton je m'arrête que je peux sentir
mon assise jeu pour inspirer inspiré par
les narines peut-être sentir l'air qui
rentre dans les poumons puis expirez par
la bouche une seconde fois j'inspire et
puis j'ai expirent en déposant le corps
sur la chaise
la seconde étape c'est le haut de
observé j'observe comment je me sens
dans mon corps ted
les tensions des relâchements comment je
me sens au niveau des émotions telles
que je suis heureux d'être ici peut-être
détendu peut-être fatigué
la troisième étape c'est le s de soin de
soi je prends soin de moi je peux
peut-être me poser la question de quoi
j'ai besoin là maintenant peut-être que
j'ai besoin de d'apprentissage de
partage
peut-être de repos comment ça me fait de
me connecter à ce besoin même si les
insatisfaits puis la dernière étape
c'est le e2 environnement je prends soin
de mon environnement
si j'ai ouvert si j'ai les yeux fermés
je vais pouvoir les ouvrir
peut-être prendre conscience de la salle
de mon entourage
peut-être que je connais mes voisins
peut-être pas peut-être échangé quelques
regards croisés des sourires
c est terminé comment vous sentez-vous
là maintenant peut-être que vous sentez
apaisé joyeux peut être indifférent
l'intention c'est d'accueillir ce qui
est là pour vous ici maintenant être
pleinement présent à soi et à son
environnement est nécessaire pour être
le leader ton demain a besoin
le leader de demain sera relié à ses
émotions à ses talents et à ses limites
ses qualités sont encore peu valorisées
dans notre société
nous avons peur de paraître fragile de
montrer nos émotions
or nous constatons qu'en niant notre
vulnérabilité notre humanité
nous devenons fragile et lorsque nous
avons peur
notre réactivité et de nous isoler de
nous séparer de nous et des autres et
nous perdons notre leadership car nous
avons choix soit de nous laisser diriger
par notre ego notre avidité ou bien
d'être responsable et de prendre en
compte la dimension plus large de notre
mission de vie et de l'environnement
je voudrais vous raconter une histoire
c'est l'histoire d'un chef indien qui
dit à son petit garçon son petit fils
j'ai deux loups qui se bat dans mon
coeur
le premier lieu loup et peureux
vindicatif envieux rancunier et sournois
le second loup et bienveillant aimant
généreux sincère et pacifique est le
petit fils une dit à son grand père mais
quel ou va gagner et le chef indien lui
dit celui que tu nourris alors comme
j'ai eu le choix voilà quelques années
nous avons tous le choix est comme une
graine si nous la nourrisson elle se
développera
parce que demain se construit
aujourd'hui qu'elle loue ferez vous le
choix de nourrir merci
[Applaudissements]